all right it's already been a really bad
week for the deep state here to talk
about the very latest developments and
help break it all down Senate Judiciary
Committee chairman Lindsey Graham you
know I had you on although when you
don't avoid the show by traveling all
over the world and you make yourself
available this is your first job I don't
understand why you say no that very bad
exactly I agree steal studying prefect
confessions this new report and the
closed-door testimony where we know
Bruce or under oath said well I told
everybody in August of 2016 it's an
under verified document and the dossier
and steal hates Trump and Hillary paid
for it you know as I do that it's
unverifiable but does it not say at the
top of a FISA warrant I just learned
this today verified well it's supposed
to be you're supposed to say under oath
to the court that the document I'm
presenting to you is accurate that's the
whole point of getting a warrant you got
to have reliable information but why is
this so important we know in August of
2016 or tells the FBI senior leadership
you got a watch this steel guy he's out
to get Trump now what do we know that
Christopher still went to the Department
of State on October the 11th to try to
get the Department of State to release
the dossier to the public for political
reasons they tell the FBI's this is 10
days before they get the first warrant
application verified so 10 days before
they applied for the FISA warrant they
were told in August that stills out to
get Trump in October still goes to the
State Department trying to get them to
release it to the public for a political
reason you know you can't even make this
up now I understand this there is a
Florida case and we might get
information from steel but we do know
any interrogatory where he was under the
threat of perjury
he actually said I have no idea of any
of this is true
fifty-fifty it passed so doesn't that
then render the dossier the dirty
Russian dossier on
verifiable was this important we should
all be concerned if our governments
getting a warning against American
citizen under the FISA surveillance act
without accurate information what do we
know we know that without the dossier
the warrant would not have been issued
people in charge tell us that we now
know that the author of the dossier
Christopher Steele was on the payroll of
the Democratic Party he was not a
reliable informant for the FBI he was
trying to destroy Trump because he's
paid by the Democrats to take Trump down
they knew all of this I should have
known all this before they applied for
the warrant so here's what needs to
happen somebody needs to go to the FISA
Court and tell them that the FBI had
plenty of notice that this guy was on
the payroll the Democratic Party and he
was out to get trumps and the dossier
was not very smart would that be a
conspiracy to commit fraud on a FISA
Court and where I grew up in New York
and I know if down in South Carolina
will you grow up you yeah you were
living in a bar I was working in a bar
till 4:30 we have similar backgrounds
where I grew up you say yes ma'am no
ma'am yes or no so yes your honor no
your honor and if you lie to the judge
it's not going to work out really well
in the end well here's the question how
could you not know that Steele should be
looked at really hard given what or said
and given his actions October 11th you
got to remember the guy who started this
still went to the State Department and I
don't know why he went to the State
Department for the expect the express
purpose of having the State Department
released the dossier before the election
that was memorialized we now know that's
the interesting part and we have Ward
more emails comes before the warrant let
me ask you it before the warrant just
like or said he told everything let me
go to robert muller for a second you
said you don't care whether or not he
testifies that's up to him Trump may
stop it but I don't know if I want that
because Mulder I want to know when did
he know there was no conspiracy with the
Trump campaign in Russia as it relates
to collusion of any kind when did he
know that why did he hire only Democrats
and even Hillary's attorney and one
attorney known for withholding
exculpatory evidence and having a really
bad track record and failing
and why was he not concerned about
Hillary's dirty Russian dossier when he
had plenty of time to look into the
medallions and fairer laws and loan
applications and taxes I would think the
Russian dossier would have been
important Robert Muller but what do I
know well I need somebody needs to look
at this like Muller looked at Trump and
here's the question why would the FBI
classify this exchange between still and
the State Department the FBI April of
this year mm-hmm Wow now this is pretty
interesting
thank class you pledged to the American
people tonight senator as the Attorney
General told you I thought you had the
best line of questioning last week that
it's important if Hillary's
investigation into criminal activity was
rigged whether or not they tried to rig
a presidential election whether a fraud
was committed against the FISA Court
whether there was leaking of Intel
weather the Intel community was
weaponized against the American people
and whether or not they tried to
bludgeon the President of the United
States with the opposition party
candidate lies to unseat a duly elected
president are all those issues on the
table you better believe it for attorney
general Barr and myself we've got to get
to the bottom of it and make sure it
never happens again is the Muller issue
dead now case closed
Thank You senator you're dismissed thank
you